the legalization of cannabis is way
bigger subject than just meaning that I
can carry cannabis and not go to jail
it's about changing the future of the
world marijuana may have a way to go
before changing the world but sales of
legal cannabis are beginning to change
the face of business no longer is hip
just for hippies blue-chip investors are
now putting their money behind legal
weed since recreational sales began in
Colorado and Washington last year the
number of publicly traded cannabis
companies has grown from 13 to 300 the
sales of legal marijuana reached almost
three billion dollars just last year
reason TV traveled to Denver Colorado
for the second annual cannabis Business
Summit to find out how legalization is
driving innovation and growth in the
thriving and legal marijuana economy one
of the exciting things for me to come to
these shows like this is just trying to
understand what industry's technologies
came out of to benefit the cannabis
industry our industry came out of
healthcare and plastic recycling and
here we are providing Chavez in
packaging in order very packaging I talk
to other industries that are coming out
of you know testing lab testing a lot of
the cultivators here a lot of the
growing light so it's it's amazing to
see how US manufacturers u.s.
technologies can adapt to a new market
you see a lot of the entrepreneurial
spirit in a lot of the ancillary
businesses within the cannabis industry
whether it's from the aspect of
extraction machine manufacturing all the
way down to people that you know print
stickers for bottles and labels it's
been how about a year and a half now
since legalization how's business been
going and I mean have you seen an uptick
or what's happening yes we really have
obviously with the the inception of
retail here in Colorado as well as in
different other areas of the state of
course it opens a whole new market for
extraction machine manufacturers because
every company that starts up it has to
have a you know some form of
manufacturing concentrate for their
clients so we've definitely seen an
increase in business associated that it
is a very new industry so there's it's
kind of like the Wild West out there
there's a lot of innovation going on
it's gonna be a shakedown period for a
while but right now you get to see a lot
of very clever new
products coming out on the market most
lighting that's used in the cannabis
industry right now is standardized 9000
watt high pressure sodium bulbs which
are full of mercury so not only are
using a thousand watts to grow a few
plants but every time you throw a bulb
out it's enough to contaminate a whole
small pond so our lighting product does
not have any mercury in it and we also
use 30% less electricity and we grow a
better quality product with that
Serna came about in March of 2014 and
because we're so focused solely on
cannabis we have seen an incredible boom
I'm was employee number eight or
something at Sunnah and now we're close
to 40 if not over and we're hiring
constantly so in over a year just over a
year we've grown exponentially and it's
not slowing down anytime soon we're
actually a traditional food packaging
company we'll take any container a tray
or a cup gas flush it with inert gas
that's found in the atmosphere as it is
nitrogen or carbon dioxide and actually
remove the oxygen content of that
package and that keeps food fresher for
longer it's pretty commonly used in the
food industry as it is and what we've
trying to do is apply for the marijuana
industry as to people who get rich in a
gold rush so the miners and the people
that sell X's and our packaging is comes
in the form of excess entrepreneurs
aren't the only ones waking up to pots
profit potential even politicians see
big opportunity in promoting legal weed
Rand Paul became the first presidential
candidate to raise money from the
cannabis industry when he held a private
fundraiser for summit attendees four
years ago you had to chase down the
presidential candidates and really
nagged them to get them to talk about
marijuana and give a position on it and
now we're seeing all of the candidates
really being asked about all the time
and being open about it and talking
about their support for states rights or
whether they're opposed to it and so on
it's hard to ignore at this point you've
got business owners you've got employees
you've got a base of tax revenue you
really got to start to treat this like
any other legal industry